(soft music)
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal, naked, large brain.
Long the master of fire,
tools, and language.
But still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable.
Yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from
our shared understanding
of the past.
Carta brings together experts from diverse
disciplines to exchange
insights on who we are
and how we got here.
An exploration made possible
by the generosity of
humans like you.
(upbeat music)
- The thing about humans,
and if you haven't thought
about it, I'm sure you will,
we can and do eat anything.
So what we can do is eat directly.
So we do, we could be
completely carnivorous,
we could be almost completely herbivorous,
if we can't eat it, like
grass, we feed it to a cow
who can eat it, or we do
what pascal does which is
takes the yeast and makes bread out of it.
And so we can also take
that cow and cook it
so we can actually get
something out of this.
I just picked this slide at random,
this is not one that I think
depicts much of anything,
but the only reason I'm
showing it is because I want
you to get a sort of idea
of the body size of what
we're gonna be talking about.
None of these animals are small.
Okay so what did they eat?
Well how do you know?
So one of the ways is to do
morphological comparisons.
So what you have here is
the skull of a very robust
australopithecine on
your right and you've got
a very early archaic hominin on your left.
As you can see that there's
a massive difference.
This is a chewing muscle
that goes through here.
It has a ridge on the top
of it's head where there's
musculature that goes all the way up,
it is a chewing machine.
These are the teeth.
So you see the size of
these teeth verses the size
of another fossil,
australopithecus afarensis,
compared to a modern human.
So you can see the different
sizes in their teeth.
There are people in this
room who do that, I don't,
but I can do it in general.
Okay what did they eat?
You can also look at force and strain,
you can use a model, so
what yovue got here is
a macaque monkey.
This is done on a macaque monkey skull,
this is not done on a live
macaque, I don't believe.
Although those were implanted in macaques.
And then this is a australopithosine,
or a cast thereof, shaped
exactly like you would
a live one if you could
and you can see where
the stress and the strain
is coming.
So what you've got is a
lot of stress across here,
which is where the chewing
musculature is gonna go
back behind here.
And so you can see that
the distribution of stress
in some places is the same,
in other places it's not
because what we're looking
at is strain deformation
of the bone following stress.
Another way of looking at it is microwear,
that's what these pictures are.
This is work that was
done by Mark Teaford and
Peter Ungar and what they say
is gorilla fine wear striae
baboon-like pits, microflakes
and it shifts to hominid
puncture crushing.
What that tells you a little
bit about what kinds of
textures these animals were eating,
but it doesn't tell you what they ate.
Well I like to go to
general principles first.
So although I'm not gonna give you models,
I'll give you some general principles.
One of those is as body size increases,
metabolic rate decreases.
Per kilo, that's not overall energetics.
So for small animals they
have to eat small packages
of high quality food that
can be processed quickly.
So you think of that galigo
monkey, galigo (mumbles).
You look at a large animal,
lots of low quality food,
processed more slowly and they
tend to be more sedentary.
And again it's not total
output of energy or total
input of energy, it is per kilo.
Well, okay so from that let's
look at what primate foods
are all about.
Primate foods break down into
sort of three categories;
insects, leaves, and fruit.
So what you're looking at
is things that are insects,
they move around a lot but
they're high in protein,
leaves are also high in
protein but very difficult
to digest, and they also
are seasonal so they will
disappear and so they
actually move, but over time.
Fruit is high in energy, I
almost showed you orangutan
fruits that do not look
like they're high in energy,
but most fruits are high
in energy and they're easy
to digest.
They are, however, like
leaves mobile in time,
they come seasonally.
You look at the primates that feed here.
You have small primates,
very small primates,
that can feed on insects.
Again, requires small
packages of food but highly
easy to digest.
You have large primates,
depicted by this gorilla,
it's again high in protein
but very hard to digest.
And gorillas done more
around as much as the
(mumbles) does.
I show you fruit, although
there's no animal that can
survive just on fruit because
you don't get the protein
content, but I show you some
monkeys that are gonna be
feeding on fruit.
You look at what these
animals do do is you get
animals along the lines
of frugivore folivores
so the large animals will
eat leaves and then they
combine that with fruit.
Small animals will either
be totally insectivorous,
or they'll combine that with fruit.
What you never have is
a primate that relies
on leaves and insects.
And that's just because a
large animal cannot capture
enough insects in order to
be able to survive itself.
Or able to survive.
So we look at this in our
body size we should've been
a frugivore folivore, right?
Okay well you know what
your diet is and I would
say that this has been
going on for a long time.
We were not folivores.
Not for a very long time.
So what do we do now
about what did they eat?
Alright this is the part
that I will be presenting
today and the data that I will present.
And these all have to
do with stable isotopes.
Stable isotopes are different
forms of the exact same
element and the one I'm
gonna be talking about is
carbon because it's gonna
be in a mineral portion of
enamel or in bone and you
don't get any kinds of
organics in that.
So what these elements, how
they differ are different
masses which means that they
react at different rates.
And that means that if you've
got something that reacts
at different rates, that
it can be distributed
differently as, say, certain
trophic levels across
different parts of the same trophic level.
And that's what we're gonna be doing.
We present that as C13, C12
those are the stable isotopes.
You've probably heard of carbon
14 which is radio carbon,
this is not a radioactive
element, isotope.
Then you get them presented
as delta C12 and it's in
per mil just to make it read--
You take a standard, you take your sample,
you compare them and the
differences, the delta.
Okay how did this all get started?
Well we know that atmospheric
CO2 is taken up by plants
by photosynthetic pathway.
In 1948 we knew that there
were plants that actually
the way in which they took
up CO2, and I have to say
that there is a man, was
at UCSD when I got here
who was one of the men
who discovered this.
C4 plants, I'm not even
gonna talk about 'em because
that wasn't done at UCSD.
But they weren't even
identified until 1967 so we've
had almost 20 years where
people thought everything
was like this.
Now what do we do now is
look at the geochemistry.
Samuel Epstein, who was at
Cal Tech, in 1971 finally
had his ah-ha moment when
he realized that all those
plants that he had been
collecting across country
and everywhere else and he
could make no sense of it
because they came out with
a bimodal distribution,
low and behold these were
two different photosynthetic
pathways.
Those two photosynthetic
pathways are actually
different kinds of plants.
So what you get here are
what we call C4 plants,
they're gonna be (mumbles)
and grasses, some sedges,
not very many of them and
many of the succulents had
the same numbers, even
though they're not C4.
They come out to be
about a minus 12 compared
to atmospheric CO2 which is minus seven.
And it's different than
it was in the past,
so we have to correct for that.
C3 plants actually take up
their material differently,
they fix in a three carbon sugar at first.
They come out to be minus 26,
there is no overlap between C3 and C4.
These are primate foods.
These are leaves, fruits,
seeds, herbaceous plants,
all those kinds of things,
those are primate foods.
These are not primate foods.
But we're not interested
in the plants, right?
We're interested in the
animals, we're gonna try to
figure out what the animals do.
The first lab study was by one
of Sam Epstein's post docs,
Michael DeNiro that was
actually my post doc advisor
and so at Cal Tech what they
did is they took grasses
and they took plants that
had a C3 pathway and they
fed it to lab rats.
And what they discovered
what that these two actually
mimicked the plants that they ate.
So they actually could see the difference.
The one issue was, well
okay but we don't know what
the plants are when we're
looking at these things
from the Pliocene, the Miocene,
and even the Pleistocene.
Well, okay you're gonna
get a number but what does
that tell you about what the plant is,
or what's going on?
At this end that's C4, you
know at this end it's C3,
what do you know about this?
How is it offset from the diet?
And what we found in this
study is that the offset
is about 10 per mil.
These are animals with simple guts,
just like you and I have.
So there was another lab
study that was done on
yama, of all things and it was done,
I believe at the University of Utah.
And what they did is
they looked at the offset
between these large
animals and their diets.
And low and behold, they
are quite different from
one another.
So that means if you're
gonna use what you thought
was the offset, which is
minus 10, you're gonna have
problems with an animal
like a yama, a big animal,
because it's not gonna
give you the same kind of
information about the diet.
This is the reason why, this
is for one of the people
in the audience, what we
have are cows which are
ungulous and they also are ruminants.
They have a very basic
stomach in the forefront
of the other parts of
their digestive system
and what they do is the
house huge vast quantities of
microorganisms and what they can do, then,
is they can actually ferment
indigestible material.
They are, cows are non-selective feeders.
If you look at the skull
of the cow it does not have
any top teeth.
All it's doing is ripping
anything up out of the ground
and taking it.
And so all the bovids in
east Africa are this kind of
animal.
The ones we're gonna
compare to our hominids.
Horses, on the other
hand, for those of you--
If you live here you know
exactly what a horse looks like.
I didn't know that much
about horse digestive system
until I was looking at
this to teach my courses.
They also have a pretty
massive digestive system,
but it's all hind gut.
It is not in the stomach,
it's in the hind gut.
So they actually are far more
selective feeders because
any toxin that comes in,
which gets taken care of by
the ruminants microorganisms,
cannot be handled by a horse.
That's why horses have
such more sensitive diet
requirements.
If you look at a horse skull
it has both upper teeth
and lower teeth, that allows
it to pick out exactly
what it wants to eat.
These are primates.
Those don't look really anything
like either one of these.
So why do we think that we
can compare our primates,
our hominids directly
to browsers and grazers?
Either zebra or to bovids in east Africa.
If you look at all living
primates, we've got a prosimian
here, you've got monkeys,
you've got an ape,
they are all C3.
If you look at old world
monkeys, whether you've got
a cercopithencine, a
colobine, what the baboons do,
what a douc langur does
in Asia, they are all C3.
Does not matter whether they
have a large stomach or not.
Baboons in very marginal ar--
I went through every study
that was done on living
primates and what you will
hear is that baboons can
eat grass.
Yes, they can.
And about five to 10% of their
diet can actually be grass
and it's only done in one
marginal area out of five
in Africa.
You also get some poop that
is C4, but when you look at
their hair or their teeth, they are C3.
So now let's go to the fossil record.
This is from (mumbles) Wood
and I really appreciate
him allowing me to show this.
What you have here are
possible archaic hom--
Possible hominids, you've
got what would be called
archaic hominins and here
you have the megadont,
the ones that I showed you before.
They you get pre-modern
homo and anatomically modern
human, I will not be going up into this.
I wanted to and there just wasn't,
I didn't think there was
gonna be enough time to do it.
So let's look a little bit
at the skeletons of some
of these.
I just picked some at random.
Julia Lee-Thorp in South Africa
can a (mumbles) doing this
and has done a phenomenal
job of preparing how
you do enamel to do
carbon isotope analysis.
What I hope you see here
is that all of these have
flared rib cages.
And Leslie Aiello once
said, "Lucy had no waist."
If you think about it,
even men have waists.
Because we have a small digestive system,
when we stand up we have
a small digestive system.
These others did not.
But they're all (mumbles)
fermentors because that's
what all of us are and our relatives are.
This is homo ergaster, a
very early homo erectus
and what I think you'll see
is that it does not look
exactly like us, he probably had a waist.
So what we're looking at is
a different size digestive
system.
So in 1999, Matt Sponheimer
and Julia Lee-Thorp published
what I believe is probably
the first paper looking
at carbon isotopes in early
hominids to figure to diet.
They came up with an average
of minus 8.3 per mil.
And quote, "This early
hominid ate large quantities
"of carbon 13 enriched foods."
And from their perspective,
the thing that made them
on the human lineage is that
we were eating C4 foods.
Alright what they did, and
I hope you can see this
in this slide, is that they
took the endpoint of C4 foods
and they took the end point of
C3 food and I'll remind you,
this is a foregut fermentor,
this is a hind gut fermentor,
it is not a simple gut.
Either any of them.
So what we have here is a
zebra and we have a gerenuk.
But I could've picked
a bunch of other ones.
I don't think you can
compare a primate to that,
but that's what they did.
And then you take homo--
This was australopithecus
afarensis I believe at eight
and then they said, "Okay
it's about halfway along
"the line, massive
quantities of C4 foods."
There is another way of
doing this and this is what
I started looking at.
And that is what if you
think about an offset of
10 per mil, which is what
simple gutted animals have now,
we do roughly, or 14 per mil.
What would be the difference in the diet?
And what you have are the
blues one are the difference
if you look at 10 per mil
and the green ones are
the ones if you look at 14 per mil.
And I'm not saying that either
one of these is correct,
it's somewhere probably in
between and probably varies
across these different species.
What I think you'll notice is
that virtually all of these
have low quantities of C4
foods if you buy my argument.
Or they are actually C3
feeders like any normal primate
would be with one exception,
and that is the very robust
ones in east Africa with
the huge massive chewing
muscles.
So now, this cannot be
sited, but Fred Grind gave me
permission to point out that
there is a new paranthropus
at 3.5 million, which would
put it way down in here,
and it is a C3 feeder.
If you look at it, it's either
a mix with very little C4
or it is C3.
So sometime in around one
million to 1.8 million
we ended up with a major
shift that those animals
became C4.
It was not true before that.
So I finished up right
now with when we get to
homo gaster or homo erectus,
the same exact number as
you saw in the australopithecine,
but here I do not think
we're looking at mostly green plants.
I think here we're looking
at meat and we're pretty sure
and I think we're gonna
have some speakers after me
that are gonna point out how
far back this probably went.
This is one of Leslie
Aiello's, again, human-like
body shape, probably the
simple gut the way we do.
I would say that probably
what we're looking at when
we have mixed C3 and C4 is
probably a mix of hunting
zebra and hunting C3
feeding browsing animals.
So my conclusions, if we
can consider variation in
diet to appetite, which most people don't,
in modern fauna, the diets
in early hominins appear
far more varied than
originally appreciated.
If we consider metabolic
differences between animals
with simple GI tracts, which
most all primates have,
and those relying on
extensive fermentation,
alternative diets become
distinct possibilities.
Now thank you.
(applause)
Oh wait.
One last one.
I just want to say I have
to thank my students,
because if it weren't for my
present and former students
you would not have heard this talk today.
(applause)
(upbeat music)